und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend den allen Katha Katastrophe
Desaster von Doha sie merken schon in
Situationen wie dieser geht es nicht
ohne Alliteration
es ist nur Fußball aber was heißt schon
nur wenn die deutsche Nationalmannschaft
das dritte große Turnier in Folge
vergeigt wenn ein ganzes Land tief
enttäuscht ist dass sich dringend einen
Lichtblick gewünscht hätte im dunklen
Winter
jenseits von Kanzler Besuchen in der
Umkleidekabine hat das Abschneiden bei
einer WM auch politische Folgen es kann
für Stimmungs hoch Sorgen wie 2006 als
die Deutschen über sich selbst jubelten
oder für das Gegenteil wir werden auch
darüber in der kommenden Zeit reden aber
erst wo war das deutscher Fußball Heiko
Klasen
die Mannschaft ist wieder zurück in
Deutschland sie ist gelandet wenn man so
will auf dem Boden der Tatsachen zurück
von einer Reise die eigentlich
märchenhaft wie aus tausend und einer
Nacht mit viel Gold und Glanz und dem
WM-Titel enden sollte tatsächlich fand
man sich aber eher in der Geschichte von
Jim Knopf und dem scheinriesen wieder je
näher man den deutschen Spielern kommt
desto mehr schrumpfen sie auf normalen
Größe weit entfernt von der eigenen
Großartigkeit das ist die harte Realität
aber das ist die Realität in dem indem
wir uns befinden vier Talent alles schon
gut aber das Ding ist
da gehört einfach mehr dazu als nur
Talent es gehört der Wille dazu sich für
den anderen aufzuopfern dahingehend
wir verstehen will warum die deutsche
Mannschaft ausgeschieden ist muss sich
nur mal das zweite Gegentor von gestern
anschauen in dessen Entstehung die
deutschen jeden Zweikampf verlieren das
DFB-Team ist in seinen letzten elf
Spielen nur einmal ohne Gegentor
geblieben gegen den Oman und stand vor
der WM in der Weltrangliste nur auf
Platz 11 das Ausscheiden also in
Wirklichkeit alles andere als
überraschend seit Jahren gibt es eine
negative Entwicklung in diesem
Zusammenhang ist es erstaunlich dass die
verantwortlichen Führungskräfte
offensichtlich nicht einmal über
persönliche Konsequenzen nachdenken es
ist hier Enttäuschung da und wird sich
in Ruhe zusammensetzen und dann
weitersehen aber für mich steht Hansi
fliegt nicht in Frage wie sieht es bei
Ihnen aus
für mich auch nicht aber es weiß ja
nicht wie andere denken da kommt dann
der DFB-Präsident ins Spiel Bernd
Neuendorf bittet in der nächsten Woche
zum Krisengipfel mit knallharter Analyse
und Analyse muss auch umfassen
die Entwicklung der Nationalmannschaft
unseres Fußballs seit 2018 seit der
letzten WM ein weiter so kann es auf
jeden Fall nicht geben
ja also keine glanzvoller Heimkehr heute
Abend mit dem Sieger Flieger Michael
Krämer ist für uns am Frankfurter
Flughafen hallo Michael wie verschämt
war denn jetzt diese Rückreise aus Katar
ja Christian um 14 Uhr unserer Zeit
heute Mittag ist die DFB
charter-maschine LH 343 in Doha
gestartet zu diesem Zeitpunkt waren
einige Spieler schon nicht mehr mit an
Bord die haben sich nämlich vorher
verabschiedet um den privaten Urlaub
anzutreten oder aber sie sind vor Ort
geblieben um weitere WM Spiele zu
verfolgen es gab dann noch mal einen
kurzen Zwischenstopp am Flughafen in
München das war gegen 19 Uhr und jetzt
vor wenigen Augenblicken ist der Rest
der Mannschaft gelandet nachdem sie
schon einige Spieler in München
verabschiedet haben ja und jetzt geht es
tatsächlich
ja ich wollte eigentlich eine kurze
zweite Frage stellen noch ein bisschen
in die Zukunft gucken Michael wenn du
mich hören kannst wir haben gerade schon
im Film von Analyse gehört wie schnell
sind denn jetzt tatsächlich Konsequenzen
zu erwarten
ja auf keinen Fall mehr heute und auch
auf keinen Fall mehr am Wochenende
sondern der DFB-Präsident Bernd
Neuendorf hat einen ganz klaren Fahrplan
genannt nächste Woche wird es das
Treffen geben mit ihm höchstpersönlich
dem DFB viel zu Präsidenten Hans-Joachim
Watzke den Bundestrainer haben sie Flick
und Oliver Bierhoff muss ich dann
aufstellen und die beiden letztgenannten
müssen dann eine erste sportliche
Analyse vorlegen und erst danach wird es
vermutlich erst Entscheidung geben
Michael Krämer am Frankfurter Flughafen
herzlichen Dank Deutschland hat ein
ernsthaftes Problem nur wie die Lösung
aussieht ist offen neues Denken ein
Aufbruch wäre dringend nötig aber
irgendwas steht irgendwie immer dagegen
das gilt für den Fußball das gilt auch
in der Politik wo heute die
Innenministerin und Minister von Bund
und Ländern über wirklich essentielles
reden über das was nötig ist für unser
Leben die sogenannte kritische
Infrastruktur und sich schwer tun ein
gemeinsames Schutzkonzept Weg finden
Jutta sonnewald
zumindest in einem Punkt waren sich die
bundesinnenministerin und ihre Kollegen
und Kolleginnen der Länder heute einig
die kritische Infrastruktur im Lande wie
Kraftwerke Krankenhäuser Bahnlinien oder
Pipelines muss besser geschützt werden
seit Beginn des ukrainekrieges ist das
Risiko einer Verwundbarkeit hier
deutlich gestiegen
stärkt auch insbesondere in
Zusammenarbeit mit der Bundeswehr auf
See zeigt die Bundespolizei mit allen
verfügbaren Kräften und Schiffen ein
deutlich verstärkte Präsenz da hat sich
die Arbeit auch ein Stück weit verlagert
nennt sie fesers ehrgeiziger Plan das
Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik in Bonn zu einer
neuen Zentralstelle im Kampf gegen
Cyber-Attacken umzubauen stößt auf
Widerstand bei den unionsregierten
Ländern ihr Argument Cyberkriminelle zu
bekämpfen sei Aufgabe der
Sicherheitsbehörden der Länder um eine
Zentralstelle des Bundes einzurichten
müsste das Grundgesetz geändert werden
wir sehen dort dass wir eine große
Aufgabe haben aber die wollen wir auch
in den Mittelpunkt stellen den Kampf
sozusagen für cybersicherheit für die
Integrität unserer
Datenstrukturen und wir wollen nicht
erst mal mit Gesetzesänderungen im
Mittelpunkt sozusagen debattieren
Johannes rundfeld von der unabhängigen
Arbeitsgruppe kritis hat das Gerangel
der innenministerinnen und Innenminister
heute verfolgt er sieht Verbund noch
Länder richtig gut aufgestellt im
Bereich schutzkritischer Infrastrukturen
ein energienetzbetreiber ist in der Lage
klar zu definieren welche der Anlagen
jetzt kritisch als kritisch gelten der
Staat selbst hat das aber nicht getan so
dass bis heute unklarheit besteht welche
Computer und Serversysteme welcher
Steuersysteme des Staates und der
öffentlichen Verwaltung selbst als
kritisches gelten und entsprechend
werden dies auch nicht geschützt um den
Schutz kritischer Infrastrukturen im
Land besser zu gewähren hat die
Innenministerin ein neues Gesetz auf den
Weg gebracht das will sie noch vor
Weihnachten durchs Kabinett bringen sagt
sie natürlich in enger Absprache mit den
Ländern
und jetzt der Blick auf weiteres was
auch noch wichtig war heute Hanna hast
du den
erstmals seit Mitte September haben
Bundeskanzler Scholz und der russische
Präsident Putin wieder miteinander
telefoniert dabei verurteilte Scholz
erneut die Angriffe Russlands und
forderte einen Rückzug der russischen
Truppen um eine diplomatische Lösung zu
ermöglichen laut Kreml bezeichnete Putin
die Unterstützung Kias durch den Westen
als destruktiv diese führe dazu dass die
Ukraine Verhandlungen mit Russland
ablehne
mit den Stimmen der Ampelkoalition hat
der Bundestag ein Gesetz beschlossen das
für Krankenhäuser vor allem für
Pflegepersonal Entlastung bringen soll
geplant ist unter anderem den
Personalbedarf realistischer zu
berechnen außerdem soll es mehr Geld für
die überlasteten Kinderkliniken und die
Geburtshilfe geben und unnötige
krankenhausübernachtungen sollen
wegfallen damit weniger Nachtschichten
besetzt werden müssen
nach einer hitzigen Debatte hat der
Bundestag außerdem eine Änderung des
Aufenthaltsrechts beschlossen geduldete
Ausländer die seit mindestens fünf
Jahren in Deutschland leben sollen
künftig einen befristeten
Aufenthaltsstatus von 18 Monaten
erhalten in dieser Zeit haben Sie die
Möglichkeit die notwendigen
Voraussetzungen für einen dauerhaften
Aufenthalt zu erfüllen dazu gehören
unter anderem Sprachkenntnisse die AFD
und ein Großteil der Union stimmten
gegen das Vorhaben
die Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es im
Norden und Nordosten noch etwas Schnee
oder Regen sonst bleibt es meist trocken
und trüb vor allem im Süden kann auch
mal die Sonne hervorkommen die
Temperatur steigt auf
-3-6 Grad in den nächsten Tagen liegen
die Temperaturen dann bei 0 bis 7 Grad
ab Montag regnet und schneit es wieder
öfter
und das war unser kurzes heute journal
in der Halbzeitpause von uns allen hier
für Sie einen angenehmen Abend viel Spaß
beim Fußball
[Musik]